- Ottawa se prépare à recevoir
Les barricades sont prêtes,
l'accès au parleme
est restreint.
(klaxons)
font leur entrée. Et certains
abababablissent même leur campet
devant le parlement.
- Une génératrice 2000 watts
au gaz.
demande la fin des restrictions
tatatataires, et il est prêt
à rester aussi longtemps
qu'il le faudra. ç ç ç ç ç ç ç ,
on va rester ici
des semaines, là!
de pacifiques, mais on est
tannés de se faire manger
la laine sur le dos.
-
des protestataires promettent
un rassemblement sanuguguguge,
d'autres font des déclarations
qui laissent perplexe.
civiles pacifiques.
- La police d'Ottawa prévient
qu'elle est prête à déposer des
accu
agissant de manière violente.
C'est un prélude à l'imposante
manifestation de la fin de
de s'avancer sur le nombre
de mans s s s s attendus
à Ottawa. Chose certaine,
des kilomètres de camion c c c t
vont paralyser le centre-ville.
Des centaines de poids lourds
et de véhicules, sépar
différents convois, approchent
d'Ottawa en provenance
et des Maritimes, notamment.
(klaxon)
L'élément déclencheur a été
la v
des camionneurs imposée
par Ottawa à la mi-janvier.
Une semaine plus tard,tétététété
le pas comme prévu.
Depuis, le mouvement s'est
élargi à une protestation
co
Certains surfent sur la vague.
MAXIME BERNIER,
chef, Parti populaire du Canada
- Nous faisons une bataille
et s'assurer qu'il y a plus
de Canadiens qui s'aperçoivent,
tout comme nous, que ces mesures
autori d d d d d d d d d d d d .
- Le chef conservateur,
Erin Odes camionneurs, comme
il l'avait promis, mais loin
des journalistes, alors que des
partis comme le Bloc québécois
distances de la manifestation.UQ
Bécancour - Nicolet- Saurel, Qc
- Ça vamamamamamamamamamamamaman
qu'autre chose; c'est pas pour
les droits des camionneurs
ou des choses comme ça.
la vaccination; la menace,lalal.
- Le gouvernement Trudeau
continue de défetititititititit.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
ministre fédéral de la Santé
- Nous sommes tous dans
dans un convoi pour sortir
le plus rapidement possi
de la COVID-19.
- Mais à ce moment-ci, ce n'est
pa